i i feel like because you were saying
that you didn't you never like lied did
you
were you never lying like your whole
life up to like 14 whatever like when
when did you start like you realized you
could lie
um i think i think it was when i
realized my parents lied to me
i'm just like ah i can't believe they've
bamboozled me like this
i just realized that i was like i
probably started to like lie a lot more
for a younger age because of i had
brothers
yeah right because like you're
constantly like you can't lie to your
parents because they're your parents
right they they
own you yeah you don't get to like yeah
because i i didn't lie to my [ __ ]
parents like i said
like i got caught right right right the
first time i attempted this so
after that i was like this is this is a
losers game i'm going to lose when i try
for me it was like when you'd like go
visit a friend or something and you'd
like
you know the friend would be like oh you
know i'm just gonna say to my parents
that we're here to do homework or
whatever but you know
we'll just go to my room and play games
and i was like no that's not gonna work
my parents would immediately see through
that [ __ ] and i would see my friend
doing being like yeah we're just gonna
do homework and the parents like okay
i'm just like
you can do that oh my god
i'm gonna do that from now on yeah i
think because you when you have like
siblings it's like
i don't know i feel like you end up
having to lie because you're always
[ __ ] fighting
yeah that's right but like i was such a
terrible thing because you have older
brothers right
yeah yeah see because i was the oldest
in the family so i had to like
teach my sister to be like listen you
can you can lie to the parents
i've seen it happen
[Laughter]
[Music]
to me learning i could lie or learning
the people i was like watching that
like one life hack youtube video that
[ __ ] that was literally an actual life
that was actually a little high life
hack oh my god
but i feel like that's why some people
are just like so bad at lying
because you sometimes you play a game of
among us you can you can tell who the
good lies from the bad lies
um i've always i i think i've always had
this you know this fear like ingrained
to me from a kid that i shouldn't lie
and even as an adult i have a harder
time lying than some other people
yeah that's why i hate playing games
like among us and like werewolf or [ __ ]
like that because
i just can't lie yeah but isn't it a fun
place to just like
you know just to have like a safe space
where you can all just [ __ ] lie and
like laugh at each other
no because i'm like i'm like i can't
trust any of you [ __ ]
like after this game is over like i
can't i don't think i'll be able to
believe anything you say because it's
fun right because it's like you get to
experience what it'd be like being
interrogated if you committed like
murderers why was that fun
i don't know it's fun seeing if you can
like if you can [ __ ] your way out of
it but you can never [ __ ] your way
out of it
we should know this because sometimes
that's why
that's why it's funny to watch
interrogation videos yeah
i'm glad i'm not that guy right now yeah
it's like the reason why i watch league
esports rather than actually wanting to
play league myself it's funny to watch
other people go through pain
yeah rather than like myself that was a
really weird tangent but that's the
closest
that's the closest comparison i can
think of people suffer not me
yeah pretty much i mean who doesn't i
don't know i think i think the reason
why our mangas
did so good is because it did give a
like a thing where you'd be like hey man
there's not many games out there where
you can just like lie and that's the
whole game it's like lying and deceiving
and that's fun to get to do that and
like blow off some steam doing i mean i
definitely
do enjoy it i've played like plenty of
games of werewolf
well i really enjoyed that among us i
just didn't get
to play enough games to really get used
to it um
because i was still at the stage where
they're asking me what i was doing i was
i i was like
i don't know what to do i don't know
what the [ __ ]
is going on i like those games it was
fun when you would like realize after
like one or two rounds you're like i
know who the
the good liar is i've got to
i never got to that stage because in my
head i'm just like how am i going to
[ __ ] my way yeah but by the time i
had started playing among us there was
already a [ __ ] meta
yeah like it's like what task were you
doing and so and so okay i know you're
innocent
like i just felt i was getting smurfed
on i i i
i really enjoyed it but i think after
like the first two weeks the novelty
really warned off on me
yeah but obviously it didn't on youtube
because it was like a headline like four
entire careers were created from that
game yeah
yeah i haven't seen anything blow up
that much in a long time it's kind of
crazy